soit entre thomas friands et pablo pino
vivien on va poursuivre notre tour des
régions à dix jours du premier tour des
élections ce soir on vous emmène en
occitanie ou un duel serré oppose
l'équipe de la socialiste sortante
carole delga et celle de jean-paul
garraud pour le rassemblement national
reportage de jonathan du prix yeahs avec
hugo lemonnier au grau du roi
le rn méditerranéen parade thierry
mariani porté par des sondages flatteurs
en paca est venu afficher son soutien à
cet homme jean paul garraud cet ancien
magistrat est donné vainqueur au premier
tour en occitanie avec 30% des
intentions de vote
les deux hommes se connaissent bien tous
deux ont quitté l air pour le rn
on a eu de nombreux sujets communs on a
créé ensemble à vendre populaire et on
est ensemble aujourd'hui voilà pour un
humain
qui est le même dans deux régions
différentes incarnations d'un parti plus
fréquentable jean paul garraud déroulent
les thèmes chers à marine le pen
ce jour là il est venu s'opposer aux
éoliennes en mer et adressé un message
aux pêcheurs et petits pêcheurs de la
mer comme eux ben nous on veut les
protéger et on veut les aider mais jean
paul garraud profite surtout de cette
petite virée en mer pour installer le
match avec la présidente de région
sortante carole delga tout le monde sait
que cette élection ce jour entre carole
delga et moi les autres candidats ne
faisons que de la figuration
certains étant là comme le candidat des
as l'air pour faire perdre le rn fait
donc tout pour aller chercher
l'électorat d'aurélien pradié le
candidat des républicains à 14% des
intentions de vote selon le dernier
sondage ifop
merci de nous accueillir ni ce qu'on
voulait faire c'est une ville très
rapide convoyant qui peut à quoi
ressemble un chez tim burton pour
contrer les assauts de l'extrême droite
le jeune député du lot met en avant une
campagne studieuse sur le fond et sans
effet de manche
c'est en tout cas ce qu'il entend
prouver à ses viticulteurs du gers
inquiets de voir leur appellation
disparaître lorsque vous vous plantez un
drapeau avec l'armagnac
ça vous permet de planter un deuxième
rapport avec les côtes de gascogne ou
est-ce que les les deux filières sont
longuement dissocier c'est ça finalement
votre méthode de campagne c'est le plus
sur le fond que sur la forme j'imagine
que c'est la méthode de tous les
candidats on espère prendre du temps
pour pour échanger couvrir la différence
entre ceux qui ceux qui font de la com
et puis ceux qui ceux qui se passionnent
pour le territoire
il ya aussi des touristes en politique
plombé par les crises internes répété au
sein de l air le numéro trois des
républicains mènent une bataille
difficile sur une ligne de crête
politique
pris en tenaille par le fn sur sa droite
et le candidat dans marche au centre
je ne supporte pas cette période des
girouettes et des opportunistes
politiques
je suggère aux représentants du
rassemblement national et elles
représentant de la république en main
dans cette région ils ont quelque chose
en commun
tous les deux sont allés la soupe d'un
côté et de l'autre
bonjour messieurs dames il est le
caillou dans la chaussure d'aurélien
pradié vincent terrail-novès et le
candidat soutenu par la majorité
présidentielle
cet excellent air de 42 ans maire en
haute garonne est venu séduire les
jeunes agriculteurs et les chasseurs
dans l'ariège les chasseurs étaient les
premiers écologistes et les premiers
défenseurs de la nature mais l'auditoire
est perplexe
son projet pour la ruralité et assimilé
par certains à celui d' emmanuel macron
je veux voter prose mais je me dis que
si je vote pour vous je conforte le
président de la république l'information
d'aujourd'hui
mais vincent terrail-novès qui part sans
étiquette lrm refuse d'endosser le bilan
du gouvernement
non mais je fais pas le service après
vente parce que d'abord je suis libre et
indépendant je n'appartiens pas à moi à
une quelconque partie je n'ai pas de
parti politique d'un parti aucun
mouvement donc c'est ma liberté c'est
mon indépendance qui me permet de dire
ce que je pense
la prime aux sortants carole delga
préfère s'en méfier l'extrême droite est
aux portes du pouvoir en occitanie alors
la présidente de région sortante semble
déterminé à porter sa voix sur des
thèmes pourtant acquis aux arènes aux
côtés de policiers municipaux
elle teste dans le quartier gambetta à
montpellier une nouvelle mesure sur la
sécurité
35 de subventions pour aider les mairies
à se doter de ces camions au mobile
parce que ça permet d'aller dans tous
les quartiers pour l'emporter carole
delga peut s'appuyer sur une liste
d'union de la gauche composée de
socialistes communistes et des figures
écologistes ayant fait le choix de ne
pas rallier europe ecologie les verts
un rassemblement qui la donnent gagnante
dans tous les cas de figure au second
tour mais pas question pour elle d'y
voir un boulevard vers une nette
victoire elle n'est jamais acquise
donc je travaille là le couteau entre
les dents aux éds ou travaillant de tous
l es 158 candidats
nous travaillons tous pour qu'ils aient
une vraie mobilisation 6e élevé fait
cavalier seul au premier tour en
occitanie carole delga peu espéré son
ralliement au second tour ainsi qu'un
report des voix de la france insoumise
la gauche pourrait ainsi faire barrage
aux airs n offrant un second mandat à la
candidate socialiste et vous le savez
vous en avez l'habitude maintenant par
souci d'équité on regarde tout de suite
toutes les listes présentes en occitanie
joue présente maintenant les membres du
match des idées ce soir thomas friands
bienvenue directeur général de
l'institut open diplomatie membres de la
république en marche et pablo pino
vivien bienvenue vous êtes journaliste
responsable éditorial de la revue
regards à ce reportage aurait tout de
suite ajouté les derniers sondages qui
sont intéressants sur le sujet celui de
l'ifop fiducial pour le figaro lci
dans les hauts de france xavier bertrand
est désormais à 34% d'intentions de vote
et sébastien chenu du rassemblement
national talonne vous le voyez à 32% et
même un deuxième tour pourrait être
compliqué pour xavier bertrand en cas de
quadrangulaires autre sondage que je
vous montre tout de suite c'est celui
d'ipsos sopra steria en paca thierry
mariani du rassemblement national est
donc donnée gagner
dans tous les cas de figure et en centre
val de loire on en parle un peu moins
souvent pourtant là aussi le rn sort en
tête des intentions de vote
pablo pino vivien une vague et rennes
est elle en train de se dessiner bas
assez clairement enfin tous les sondages
le disent depuis maintenant un petit
bout de temps et ils font que monter le
fn va devenir à mon avis le 20 juin où
et surtout le 27 juin prochain le
premier parti de france dans les
régionales ils risquent de gagner
plusieurs régions où il avait dit le
paca mais aussi mais aussi les hauts de
france
moi je pense que ça fait aussi plusieurs
mois maintenant voire plusieurs années
qu'on le dit on a un déplacement de la
polarité en fait le centre de polarité
du débat politique s'est déplacé vers la
droite aujourd'hui vous avez un bloc des
droites qui représentait en gros par lr
om et l air avec des dd il ya quand même
des lignes en france exactement il ya
des nuances entre entre ces deux parties
est vous avez le rassemblement national
un peu plus sur la droite mais aussi
beaucoup des études le démontrent
il ya une porosité très grande ya
toujours une porosité très grande en
fait entre l'extrême droite et la droite
et aujourd'hui on le voit vous l'avez
vous que vous avez montré dans les
autres ans vous aviez bertrand et
sébastien chenu qui sont en fait qu'ils
sont en train de ceux entre guillemets
tirer la bourre en fait sur des sujets
mais qui sont honnêtement les électeurs
arrivent pas très bien à comprendre
parfois qui qui est qui exactement et
qui défend quoi exactement la même chose
entre thierry mariani et renaud muselier
dans l'est dans les dents le paca dans
le pack à moi j'ai lu pas mal d'articles
qui parlait des lecteurs qui étaient
complètement déboussolés et qui savait
plus très bien en fait exactement ce que
défend d'être nommé jeudi ce que
défendent et thierry mariani quelle
était la différence en plus que thierry
mariani vient lui même de la droite
il vient lui-même de la droite renaud
muselier a fait une alliance enfin une
plus ou moins il y en a il a accepté sur
sa liste des candidats de la république
en marche donc en fait tout là toute la
carte le paysage politique à droite est
brouillée
après ses sens où la d'après vous
exactement d un gros challenge et
surtout ce qu'il faut le dire vous avez
parlé de l air et du rassemblement
national vous n'avez pas parlé de la
gauche et pour vous avez raison et pour
cause parce que la course n'est présente
presque nulle part au 2e tour en
situation de l'emporter à part peut-être
dans les pays de loire mais sinon la
gauche est balayé parce que ou bien elle
n'a pas réussi à s'unir mais surtout à
n'a pas réussi à porter un projet parce
que dans les hauts de france par exemple
elle est unie et à moins de 20 % à 17 %
thomas frei j'ai l'impression que fait
le processus que décrit mon confrère ici
c'est vraiment le moi je dirais un peu
différemment c'est la trump isation de
la vie politique française
intronisations parce qu'on a très peu il
s'appelle marine le pen en france
d'ailleurs on l'a vu l'espèce de savante
orchestration du conseil spécial de
trump steel band de créer une coalition
d extrême droite européenne
clem c'est que trump c'est quoi c'est un
clown qui ne s'est pas dirigé et qui
vient faire croire au peuple qu'il est
capable de défendre les intérêts
populaires alors qu'il est en train de
l'est de les saboter et on l'a vu
l'héritage du trump heist aux etats unis
c'est une explosion des inégalités
c'est un bras de fer complètement failli
avec la chine lardons un bilan
économique il n'était pas si mauvais que
cela avant l'arrivée du coc et non mais
c'est la conjoncture mondiale elle était
bonne pour tout le monde et c'est pas
l'explosion
l'explosion du système fiscal américain
qui supprime la cohésion sociale avec
l'obamacare et qui fait augmenter la
distribution des dividendes aux prêts
auprès des très très très très hautes
fortunes américaines qui a fait la
conjoncture économique américaine c'est
la conjoncture du commerce international
des politiques monétaires extrêmement
laxiste donc on a la même en europe
en france elle s'appelle marine le pen
qui n'est d'ailleurs pas plus caustique
et que donald trump c'est à dire qu'un
coup c'est l'euro un coup c'est pas
l'euro un coup c'est les frontières un
coup c'est pas les frontières
un coup il faut des vaccins à coup il en
faut pas être star donc on a le même
type de cloud la trépidation de la vie
politique française c'est aussi le fait
que de la même manière que donald trump
s'est emparé du parti républicain
américain qui était la droite américaine
de la même manière le rpt le
rassemblement national qui correspond à
la mouvance rebelle east s'est emparé de
la droite française et quand vous voyez
que la droite les républicains soit
c'est le fournisseur officiel des
candidats du rassemblement national
comme thierry mariani qui va gagner en
paca soit c'est le pourvoyeur officielle
des idées du front national en ayant
guillaume pelletier qui annonce connerie
sur connerie à la tête des républicains
va vous voyez qu'il ya effectivement la
trump isa site rump isation la droite
française en particulier du parti et
puis et c'est là où on peut espérer
peut-être en sans passer par la caste
rebelles même c'est que la trump isation
la vie politique française
ça pourrait permettre de faire émerger
un joe biden à la française à l'eau au
moment où on parle du potentiel premier
voyage diplomatique de joe biden en
europe
c'est l'occasion de se réjouir pour moi
le joe biden à la française c'est
emmanuel macron puisque il a mis en
place un plan de relance qui n'est
certes pas en termes de montant de
milliard comparable à celui que joe
biden est en place mais en même temps on
parle pas du même système social de la
même caste sociale non plus il faut
comparer ce qui est comparable en france
on a un système social qui est
extrêmement résilient mais en terme d'
approche de lutte contre l'extrême
précarité de prévention l'extrême
pauvreté de cohésion sociale et de se
défendre sa à l'idée d'aller chez elf à
l'échelle de l'union européenne
c'est-à-dire à l'échelle continentale
qui est compact comparable à l'échelle
américaine
je pense qu'on peut avoir
un job haydn à la française qui serait
la boucle sans passer par là castrum de
la trempe isation la vie police voulait
réagir à la comparaison de jeu byden
emmanuel macron et on passe au deuxième
thème moi c'était surtout la comparaison
marine le pen donald trump
en fait je vois pas trop le rapport
parce que au contraire moi je trouve
marine le pen excessivement encore
ticket je pense que effectivement ils
sont en train de gagner une bataille la
bataille des idées ce réna émond de
sujets il y avait une étude kantar
public il ya moins d'un mois qui
démontrait que sur les sujets de
l'immigration par exemple vous avez une
majorité de français qui trouvent qu'il
ya trop d'immigrés en france sur la
question de la sécurité vous avez une
majorité de français qui veulent plus de
justice beaucoup plus forte à l'égard
une réponse pénale beaucoup plus forte à
l'égard des petits délinquants et sur
tous ces sujets là c'est exactement le
programme du front national et il est
relativement clair et vous l'a dit
erratique sur certains sujets peut-être
sur les vaccins ou quoi que ce soit mais
en vérité moi je la trouve la question
de la nation la souveraineté de la
nation c'est quelque chose qui porte
donc que l'extrême droite porte dans son
programme depuis maintenant très
longtemps qui est en train de déborder
effectivement à d'autres endroits dans
le dans le champ politique mais je la
trouve très critiqué et il s'avère que
eh ben elle rencontre un électorat qui
ait l'électorat
l'ancien électorat frontiste et qui
maintenant est au rassemblement national
qui est de plus en plus nombreux mais
enfin parce qu'on est en train de perdre
parce que les les progressistes entre
guillemets le camp progressiste et je
sais plus trop d'ailleurs ce que veut
dire le camp progressiste parce que là
une des raisons pour lesquelles
aujourd'hui marine le pen est aussi haut
c'est précisément parce que des gens lui
ont savonné la planche et que et ces
gens-là ça s'appelle les gens qui ont
été au pouvoir ça s'appelle qui
s'appelle emmanuel macron avec gérald
darmanin et toutes les lois sur le
séparatisme et c'est qu'ils sont passés
ça s'appelle françois hollande avec la
déchéance de nationalité ça s'appelle
nicolas sarkozy avec la tout ce qu'il a
pu faire
la réponse pénale et c'est donc au bout
d'un an on est en train de récolter les
dés de la tempête en fait qu'on a des
graines pour l'assommer je voudrais
revenir sur un point sur lequel je me
trouvais en désaccord avec vous c'est
que c'est pas parce qu'on est populaire
qui ont décortiqué en l'occurrence here
s'il suffisait d'être populaire par
exemple en promouvant la peine de mort
ce qui serait majoritaire en france
aujourd'hui d'après les sondages c'est
pour autant qu'on est critiqués en
l'occurrence attrayant
un liquide liquidation absolue de
l'héritage des lumières de l'héritage du
progrès social et politique en france
donc gelé pour moi le fascisme arctique
et oui bien sûr mais le camp je
maintiens ce que disait je pense que
marine le pen n'a pas le cortex cérébral
qu'il faut pour diriger un pays comme la
france et j'en veux pour preuve le fait
que vous avez parlé la notion de
souveraineté il me semble pas falloir
être d'extrême droite pour savoir
défendre ses intérêts nationaux
et en l'espèce je crois que la proche
d'une stratégie européenne pour défendre
notre souveraineté
pour le coup il est peut-être un peu
plus complexe mais en tout cas elle est
beaucoup plus qu'un ticket est beaucoup
plus efficace surtout pour défendre les
intérêts sur ces sites c'est votre var
et je suis d'accord on peut défendre ça
elle elle défend genre l'idée de la
souveraineté nationale
le retour au franc là vous avez raison
la sur le sujet on sait pas trop elle
change souvent d'avis mais enfin c'est
son ca propositions dit
autre thème important ce soir la réforme
des retraites la petite phrase
d'emmanuel macron à la semaine dernière
a relancé le débat c'était peut-être
n'ayant le but prendre le pouls des
différentes forces en présence et bien
des réactions il en a eu celle de
geoffroy roux de bézieux d'abord c'est
un débat de la présidentielle il faut
que tous les candidats se positionne
nous dit le patron du medef dans les
échos et il ajoute ceci c'est la seule
réforme sociale qui touche tout le monde
elle a donc besoin d'une légitimité
démocratique
par contre il faudra agir dès septembre
sans attendre il refuse une réforme
rustine en trois mois sinon il faudra y
revenir après la présidentielle et les
français n'y comprendront rien gérard
larcher a aussi donné son avis était ce
matin sur france 2 l'horaire sociale des
retraites élite indice mensuel l'état
dispensable il appartient au chef de
l'état et au premier ministre de décider
quand est-ce qu'on engage elle doit être
différents de ce qui est s'est terminée
quand même assez piteusement en février
2020 sur à 49,3 et avant de vous
demander ce que vous en pensez y si en
plateau on va demander l'avis de
françois aubril bienvenue et merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation dans ce
match des idées vous êtes président de
la cfe cgc la réforme des retraites est
indispensable
en fait ça veut rien dire la réforme des
retraites est indispensable le système
de retraite français il serait forme en
permanence depuis qu'il existe
il ya des réformes qui sont un peu plus
importante
plus structurantes mais l'adaptation des
systèmes des régimes leur évolution leur
convergence
en fait il ya en permanence il ya pas
une seule année qui se passe sans que
les partenaires sociaux qui gèrent les
différents régimes et avec un poids
différent mais sans que on remettre en
question un certain nombre de paramètres
donc prétendre comme le pouvoir l'avait
prétendu en 2018 qu'on peut remplacer la
complexité la sophistication et
l'efficacité de l'ensemble des systèmes
qui fonctionnent un peu comme une
horlogerie aujourd'hui dans le système
de retraite par répartition qu'on peut
le remplacer comme ça d'un claquement de
doigt par un régime unique soit disant
universel soit disant meilleur alors que
tout démontrer le contraire
de toute façon ça à l'évidence c'est
abandonner enfin je ne sais pas si c'est
abandonner mais en tout cas il
semblerait bien que ce soit abandonné et
pour le coup c'est vraiment une très
bonne chose mais moi je ne reprends pas
du tout à mon compte cette idée qu'il
faudrait un grand soir de réforme des
retraites je crois que c'est tout l'un
vers ce qu'il faut faire il faut
continuer avec pragmatisme avec
intelligence avec solidarité à faire
évoluer nos différents dispositifs parce
que c'est nécessaire
en tout endroit parce qu'il ya des
crises économiques parce qu'il ya des
équilibres démographiques qui se modifie
faut anticiper
je crois que jusque là les partenaires
sociaux ils se sont plutôt bien
distinguer dans la façon dont il gérait
les différents régimes par rapport à ce
que d'autres responsables politiques
dans d'autres plans ont été capables de
faire
donc quand je crois roux de bézieux dit
faut surtout pas une réforme rustine
fait un peu à la va vite
vous vous dites tout au contraire c'est
par petites touches justement qu'on fait
avancer le système non moi je pense
qu'il faut poser les bonnes questions au
bon endroit il était responsable partout
la question de l'agirc-arrco par exemple
vous savez la retraite complémentaire
eh bien il est posé c'est un régime qui
a constitué des réserves ces réserves
sont entamées bien entendu par la crise
on est tenu parce que c'est la règle
d'avoir six mois de réserve ainsi mois
de pension inversées en termes de
réserves ça fait quand même ça faisait
63 millions d'euros et d'ailleurs ça
faisait beaucoup plus au pouvoir
puisqu'il voulait justement finances et
là ça une partie sa réforme et notamment
la convergence du public vers le régime
universel en siphonnant les réserves de
l'argile carco quand été constitué par
les cotisants depuis des dizaines
d'années donc vous voyez bien ça fait
envie d'une certaine façon la
responsabilité assumée et des
gestionnaires de différents régimes
parce que eh bien ça brille alors il se
trouve que effectivement la crise a
entamé par déficit de cotisation essart
on sait bien pourquoi ces réserves il va
falloir trouver des solutions
d'adaptation mais nous on n'est pas
stressé je crois qu'il faut que tout le
monde se calme
il ya beaucoup d'experts qui travaillent
sur les sujets j'entendais ce matin à la
radio un ancien ministre responsable du
parti au pouvoir qui disait les réserves
et les l'arsel pardon les retraites si
ça se trouve demain il y en aura plus
etc
mais c'est pas sérieux de dire ça c'est
n'importe quoi les régimes is évoluent
ils sont stables on parle quand même de
plus de 300 milliards d'euros qui sont
gérés de façon continue et par
anticipation donc sur l'agirc-arrco il
va falloir prendre des mesures
d'adaptation comme on l'a toujours fait
et bien les différents partenaires vont
se rencontrer ils vont discuter ils vont
peut-être devoir négocier
et puis de toute façon au passage je
vous ferai observé que les équilibres
des régimes ils sont extraordinairement
tributaire des prévisions que l'on fait
de marche économique de taux de
croissance et que les taux de croissance
en ce moment ils sont réalisés quasiment
tous les jours un jour on en dit en 2021
ce sera à 7% qui ce sera 5 % 8 3% puis
6% et suivant que vous modifiez le
paramètre d'un demi pour cent
bah ça change énormément les prévisions
à terme puisqu'on a des effets
cumulatifs et les prévisions que fait le
corps sur les réserves donc le le
conseil d'orientation des retraites
il fait des prévisions à 2030 à 2040 à
il ya même
anticipation à 2070 pour tout vous dire
qui sait ce qui se sera passé entre
aujourd'hui et 2070
donc moi je pense qu'il faut je le
répète que tout le monde se détendent un
peu hein quand les vies de créer des
problèmes là où il y en a pas et qu'on
laisse les responsables faire
correctement leur travail ce qu'ils ont
l'habitude de faire et ce qu'ils ont
fait la preuve qu'il faisait très bien
c'est intéressant ce que vous dites
parce qu'on a quand même le sentiment
que ça va être l'un des grands sujets de
la campagne et surtout un grand sujet
pour le ou la présidente qui serait élu
en 2022 jeu si vous permettez on réagit
un petit peu en plateau et je reviendrai
vers vous dans un instant un françois
avril thomas friands en effet c'est un
sujet qui est extrêmement important et
il mérite d'être traité en perdre
présidentielle je sais pas s'il faut
attendre les campagnes pour parler des
vrais sujets et il me semble que
gouverner c'est l'art de parler des
vrais sujets donc en l'occurrence le
mandat d' emmanuel macron cours jusqu'à
2022 il a été élu sur un programme kerk
claire qui comportait une réforme des
retraites jusqu'à preuve du contraire il
a toute la légitimité démocratique de
gouverner jusqu'à la fin de son mandat
et donc s'il décide d'aborder ce
chantier d'ici la fin de son mandat il
me semble que yahia reinhardt il n'y a
rien à redire à ce sujet là où il ya
peut-être quelque chose à prendre en
considération c'est qu'on n'est toujours
pas sortie d'une crise sanitaire et
social extrêmement graves peuvent être
que les français sont pas prêts
emotionnellement politiquement à perdre
et on a cette difficulté de la réforme
des retraites
y compris parce qu'on n'a pas encore
totalement de clarté sur les
conséquences de moyen terme sur nos
hypothèses de croissance par exemple de
la sortie de crise est peut-être qu'il y
aura une vague qui nous remettrait dans
une situation encore plus catastrophique
sur le problème de macro économique mais
il me semble que c'est pas parce qu'on a
pris 20 points de dettes en pipe pour
traiter la crise qu vide qu'il faut
mettre qu'on avait des déficits
structurels il y a une un système de
retraite qui est qui ce déséquilibre
naturellement lié aussi au fait qu'il
est co fondé sur 42 régimes spéciaux qui
sont absolument illisible et souvent
très illégitime à comparer les uns aux
autres et qui par ailleurs dans une
société où la mobilité professionnelle
compte beaucoup ne favorise pas la
mobilité en tout cas le fait de ne
préserver ses droits au long la mobilité
donc il me semble que l'idée d'une juste
d'une réforme des retraites systémique
qui remette à plat qui sera basé sur un
principe de justice sociale et qu'ils à
l'efficacité de la mobilité
professionnelle n'est pas idiote et
quand
et quant à la légitimité démocratique du
président la république pour la traiter
et la mettre en oeuvre puisqu'il a été
lui aussi sur ce sujet il me semble que
c'est pas vraiment le sujet oui mais
françois avril nous dit pas de panique
et pas de précipitation un panneau mais
en fait le problème en fait c'est que
actuellement la seule chose que fait le
gouvernement
on ne se pose que des questions d'agenda
et monsieur mort il l'a très bien dit il
a dit on dit la réforme des retraites
non sait pas de quoi on parle parce que
la seule chose qui importe au ministre
et au président qui maintenant est en
campagne c'est de savoir quand est ce
qu'on va là comment c est ce qu il vaut
mieux pour des raisons d'agenda l'a
commencée en septembre pour en gros dire
on va reculer l'âge légal de la retraite
à 64 ans on va faire des petits
aménagements on va commencer à parler de
la retraite à points et c'est pour en
vérité savonner la planche pour xavier
bertrand parce que du coup xavier
bertrand il sera il sera un peu bloquée
si jamais il a une prétention
présidentielle parce qu'il pourra plus
dire voici ma croûte fait dix femmes
passent la route à 64 on bat lui pour a
pu le dire puisqu'il a il aurait pu
rappeler dans son programme tout à fait
et le reste en fait on n'en parle pas
tellement c'est à dire que je sais ça
gression ces raisons que si on avait une
discussion d'agenda uniquement ce serait
un peu stérile mais quand vous écoutez
les ministres c'est uniquement ça ce que
dit bruno lair
il a fait que dans notre gouvernement on
a un ministre qui est là pour travailler
avec les parlementaires sur qu'est ce
qu'on met à l'ordre du jour à
l'assemblée nationale au sénat
11h10 démocratique totalement scène et
il me semble que quand vous avez une
économie qui viennent qui représentent
30 % de la dépense publique
il semble que juste effectivement se
mettent d'accord sur le calendrier ça a
du sens
néanmoins l'intention du présent la
république sur la réforme des retraites
en tout cas c'était au coeur de sa
campagne et il s'est attaqué à la
réforme de nombreux mois avant que la
crise du covin interviennent l'intention
elle éclaire un revenu de retraite à
points qui soit équilibrée pour que les
générations futures s'y retrouvent et
qu'ils favorisent la mobilité sociale et
qui supprime les injustices il ya au 42
régimes spéciaux peut-être que la
réforme sera présentée différemment
peut-être que le rajouter affiné
wallonne de la crise du comité mais il
me semble que il n'ya pas qu'un sujet
l'agent la réforme des retraites un
objet connu alors il ya quand même une
question d'agenda c'est est ce que les
partenaires sociaux ont été prévenus
pour l'instant est ce qu'ils ont été
convoqués à quelque chose je sais pas à
l'elysée ou chez le premier ministre a
priori ils ne l'ont pas été vous pouvez
peut-être nous répondre à ça vous avez
été contacté vous vous commencez à être
contactés ou emmanuel macron et les
autres ont sorti leurs phrases un peu
comme ça non non il n'y a rien du tout
dans aller du tout dans l'agenda on en
parle entre nous bien sûr on a des
contacts entre partenaires sociaux
mais vis-à-vis du gouvernement ou cas on
n'a aucun rendez-vous dans l'agenda moi
je voudrais juste déconstruire si vous
me le permettez de trois choses qui font
partie des éléments de langage et de la
com que je viens d'entendre de façon ça
fait deux ans qu'on a les mêmes éléments
de langage 1 a changé c'est ça un peu
qui inquiète
d'un autre côté visiblement le président
macron il a l'air de considérer enfin de
se rendre à nos arguments que le projet
de réforme du système unique il était
trop complexe trop trop brutale d'une
certaine façon et qu'il allait créer des
dysfonctionnements ils l'abandonnent et
moi je dis que c'est une très bonne
décision
je salue toujours les td les décisions
de l'exécutif et du président quand
elles sont bonnes en l'occurrence
l'abandon de la réforme systémique
universel par points
c'est une très bonne chose mais après
dire que la retraite c'est un sujet
parce que c'est 30 % de la dépense
publique s'est globalisée de toute façon
c'est un discours qu'on connaît bien
mais qui amalgame tout elle est un peu
plus de 300 milliards d'euros qui
représente 15% du pib
en vérité c'est assimilé dans les
critères de maastricht la dépense
publique mais c'est tout simplement
l'argent dé l'argent des cotisants dans
un système par par système par version
part comment dire par répartition donc
c'est pas la même dépense publique les
salaires des fonctionnaires ou des
choses comme ça il faut savoir de quoi
on parle
faut pas tout mélanger les torchons et
les serviettes et l'objet de la réforme
on le sait bien
c'était de faire baisser le poids la
masse globale des retraites de 15% du
pib à 12% qui est la moyenne européenne
l'exemple suédois qui nous a été donnée
on l'a assez facilement décoder c'est
une autre façon de dire eh bien
aujourd'hui en moyenne les gens passent
20 ans de leur vie en retraite c'est
assez 1 on est passé depuis 1950 à
aujourd'hui de 6 ans de sa vie en
retraite à 20 ans maintenant le progrès
doit s'arrêter là il faut il faut
considérer que c'est assez les retraites
c'est trop ben moi je dis que tout ça se
discute
et comme le faisait remarquer un de vos
débatteurs tout à l'heure il ya
comment dire un engagement du président
à faire une réforme moi je veux bien que
le président ait pris des engagements
mais il faudrait qu'il dise exactement
quels sont les engagements qu'il a pris
est-ce qu'il a pris l'engagement
vis-à-vis de la commission européenne à
ce que la somme totale des retraites
passe de 15 % du pib à 12% si c'est
l'engagement qu'il a pris qu'ils le
disent qu'ils disent la vérité mais qui
viennent pas nous vendre une forme soit
disant plus juste un système plus facile
à comprendre
moi j'entends aussi l'argument des 42
system que c'est complexe que personne
n'y comprend rien vous savez il ya 360
muscles dans le corps si vous en
supprimer la moitié le corps il marche
pas mieux
donc il faut au moins moi moi je ne
comprends pas cette magie des chiffres
et de toute façon si vous supprimez les
régimes spéciaux ça ne change rien
puisque de toute façon les engagements à
verser des pensions qui sont dans les
régimes il demeure jusqu'à la mort des
individus qui ont ces droits là et donc
de toute façon vous pouvez pas les
supprimer les régimes spéciaux
c'est pas vrai c'est factice vous dites
qu'il n'existe plus mais en vérité les
engagements il demeure et donc vous avez
insisté qui est beaucoup plus illisibles
et par ailleurs le gouvernement dans son
système proposé d'en créer un 43e régime
spécial en changeant l'assiette de
cotisation tout ça c'est des
problématiques qu'on a posés et moi je
dis que de toute façon on a eu raison
parce que les raisons de l'abandon du
système bien sûr c'est la crise qu vide
mais je dois vous dire pour avoir
l'exacte mémoire de l'évolution des
événements
de toute façon on était dans une phase
où la prise de conscience et était de
plus en plus générale que la proposition
qui nous a été fait était une position
proposition absolument un faisable
ingérable donc méfiants et servez vous
en toutes matières agir avec pragmatisme
les gens qui gèrent les régimes le vous
disiez tout à l'heure excusez moi je
termine là dessus on sait très bien que
sur totalement le système est en déficit
mais non c'est pas vrai en fait c'est
pas vrai si vous lisez attentivement les
rapports du corps et ils sont plus lien
pratiquement tous mes trois mois
maintenant
et bien c'est parce que dit le rapport
du cor il ya des déficits qui sont
conjoncturelles il ya deux conjoncture
les conjonctures économiques et les
conjoncture démographique et s'agissant
de la conjoncture démocrate
démographique
on va plutôt vers quelque chose dans une
amélioration c'est la fin du preppy boum
ça prendra des années
mais structurellement les régimes de
retraite de toute façon ils sont pas en
déficit structurel sadek large et 300 je
vais répondre thomas friands et pablo
pied il ya peut-être un seul point
d'accord que j'ai avec notre intervenant
sait l'importance du pragmatisme et en
l'occurrence le pragmatiste il est pas
rendez vous dans ce discours puisqu'on
nous dit d'un côté il ya par d'ordre du
jour mais président de la république
prend l'engagement dabo de la réforme
systémique on dit qu'on ne sait pas
qu'elle est contenue la réforme des
retraites puis en même temps on nous dit
qu'il va en créer un 43e régime spécial
donc la confusion générale dans laquelle
se ce cet appel au président la
république à dire la vérité sur ses
engagements prétendu auprès de la
commission je le trouve un peu
bizarroïdes
moi ce que j'ai envie de dire très
simplement c'est que le présent
république a fait campagne sur un
programme ce programme il était il a été
présenté aux prêts auprès du parlement
avec une réforme cette réforme a été
suspendue au moment d'une crise sans
précédent qui a des conséquences
sociales extrêmement longue
la réforme l'esprit la réforme n'a pas
particulièrement vocation à être
révolutionné en tout cas si ça l'est
c'est pour tenir compte d'une
vulnérabilité particulière qui vient de
la crise du coc vide
est ce que ça sera avant ou après la
campagne présidentielle je pense que
pour une réforme de cette ampleur là le
temps parlementaire étant tellement
important que c'est peut-être ça le
sujet de l'agenda c'est aussi pouvoir
respecter le temps la démocratie le
temps du paritarisme aussi puisque les
partenaires sociaux sont concernés
ça c'est un discours de pragmatisme la
confusion générale sur le mensonge par
rapport à la commission européenne
j'achète pas trop leur minerai six
minutes exactement il faut faire très
attention en fait moi ce qui ressort du
discours de monsieur omer il enfin ce
que je vois en fait ce que je vois
pointer son nez c'est le front social en
fait c'est ça en fait qui risquent de
réapparaître si jamais emmanuel macron
remet cette remet cette réforme sur le
tapis parce que là vous avez la cfe cgc
mais derrière vous avez aussi la cfdt
laurent berger qui a dit qu'il n'était
pas trop d'accord vous avez la cgt qui a
décidé de faire la politique de la de la
chaise vide
et qui dit si jamais la réforme est
remis sur le tapis ils vont remettre des
gens dans la rue ils vont remettre la
france en grève et dans un moment où le
gouvernement a besoin d'une reprise
économique ils ont besoin des points de
croissance entre septembre et on va dire
l'élection présidentielle si jamais y'a
pas ces points de croissance parce que
la france est bloquée je pense que ça
peut être très problématique
politiquement à la fois pour le pour le
gouvernement mais aussi pour tous les
députés qui après deux vont se
représenter dans les problématiques pour
le pour le pays enfin pour le président
sur le plan politique mais ça peut
surtout être problématique pour le pays
sur le plan de l'activité économique
mais dont il va falloir il va falloir ne
pas faire preuve d' arrogance vis-à-vis
des vis-à-vis des partenaires sociaux
comme le président de la cei faisant je
sais qu'ils aient pas dire oui c'est du
confusionnisme enlever les écouter parce
qu'on peut pas dire c'est du
confusionnisme ils disent n'importe quoi
je comprends bien ce que l'audience
était le cas mais il me semble que pour
vous poser la question de la jna tout à
l'heure le sujet c'est vraiment de
savoir si on a le temps de mettre en
place cette réforme avec les partenaires
sociaux et le parlement
c'est ça la question là je ne viendrai
pas ce que c'est un sujet qui vous
passionne je le sens bien et du coup il
y avait deux autres thèmes qu'on n'a pas
pu traiter ce soir en tout cas je vous
remercie infiniment merci françois avril
d'avoir été avec nous et merci à tous
les deux ans à participer à ce match des
idées c'est donc la fin de cette
émission se retrouvent demain à 18
heures et à 22h37 heure et demie bonjour
chez vous oriane mancini recevra
notamment clément bonne secrétaire
d'état chargé des affaires européennes
je vous souhaite une excellente soirée
sur public sénat
pour revoir ce programme en replay sur